for external members who would have
views which they've expressed publicly
we thought would lead to more activism
and I think that is absolutely how
things have turned out so the fact that
there was a clearly Defined inflation
Target symmetric set by the chancellor
with a structure which encouried which
encode activism both raising rates and
lowering rates I think that is at the
the heart of why in monetary policy
terms things have succeeded and the
final thing I would say because you
asked me a rather big question the big
change which then happened after 2010
was the introduction of the financial
policy committee the the change in the
nature of the bank's responsibility for
macro Prudential but also micro
potential
um
leadership and there I think it's more
challenging we have a much shorter track
record than our monetary policy and the
jury is still out as to whether this has
worked I hope it does but clearly the
target is much less
clearly specified
there isn't an obvious symmetry
and we haven't seen the kind of open
debate and um and and an expression of
view
during the FPC that we've seen in the
MPC and so I think those are issues
which um are still a matter of of
concern okay the monetary policy side
has worked and um we are where we
started 25 years ago really good
everything Mr Osborne we'd like to
comment on that looking back how do you
think operational Independence has
worked no I well I broadly um agree with
Ed which I'm finding I do more these
days than I used to
um and it it was never there was never
any kind of question in my mind when I
came into office in 2010 that I would
substantially change or in fact change
in any way
the the monetary policy Arrangements we
made substantial changes which I'm sure
you're going to come on to as it alluded
to to financial supervision and macro
prudentials
um measures but
um the we we basically I stuck with the
the remit
um and the approach to monetary policy I
would say one thing um and Lord King is
here and he was the governor at the time
I did think there was a responsibility
amongst the principals to make this
Arrangement work
uh you know I think there's a real
responsibility for the governor of the
bank the chancellor exchecker the prime
minister in particular to make these
Arrangements work so you can you can
prescribe in legislation
um all sorts of
Frameworks but if the individual's
concerned don't want to make it work
then then you are going to start kind of
grinding through the gears of the
British constitution and I think you saw
that at last autumn in Britain uh when
you had a government a conservative
government that did not particularly
value the then governor of the bank of
England made no sick of it and ended up
heavily depending on the bank of England
in a crisis that they had created so uh
I I when I became chance in 2010 my
number one priority was actually to
establish a good working relationship
with Mervin King and make sure that not
only would we have a kind of formal
relationship in terms of exchanging
letters and and the like but that we
could have a proper informal partnership
which didn't in any way compromise his
independence but enabled us to both
fulfill our functions of trying to make
sure the British economy was a stable
and prosperous place can I just ask you
just for attention it will do is just in
terms of that relationship which is very
interesting and both of you and
obviously Lord King have that experience
of I just want to just get a sense of
how those kind of meetings work those
informal relationships I mean can you
just talk us through maybe without
giving a specific example but try and
give us some light on how that
relationship Works between the governor
and the chancellor so that you're
sharing views without actually
infringing Independence because this is
a sort of gray area and you could say
even to mix financials a black box in
terms of how Independence Works in
practice so could could you Mr Osborne
just I mean so you know I think the the
first thing I'd say is that I guess I
was fortunate during the six years I was
Chancellor that we never had a really
sort of stressful situation where uh
that was a kind of strong institutional
difference in Outlook between the bank
and the treasury and the rest of the
government so
um you know it wasn't kind of tested the
destruction this relationship either
with Merlin or with Mark Harmony
um but there was certainly the way I
first I started you start with respect
you know you start with enormous respect
I think as the uh the minister for the
bank of England governor and their
officials and the job that they have to
do and you have to respect that it's
they're not or servants or I hate the
kind of um
supplies more to the Civil Service
that's you know we're the Masters as the
ministers and the civil servants of the
servants that's not you know these are
two
different professions
and so you start I started with a lot of
respect for
um Bill King and his colleagues and a
respect for their role
um and then you know what I sought to do
I think it was by the way
um entirely appropriate but Mervyn King
had reached out to me as Shadow
Chancellor and had met with me on a
couple of occasions beforehand so that
there was already uh you know we had met
and established that relationship
um
and I guess the main you know the main
thing it sounds you know a bit old
school but it didn't feel like it was we
would have dinner once a month
either at the bank of England or or at
number 11. oh the treasury I mean it was
generally
better food and better drink at Bank of
England as much
but uh
um and that was a you know and the only
people that I would have with me would
be the permanent secretary
uh at the time Nick McPherson and my
most senior special advisor Rupert
Harrison
and Mervin would have his private
secretary with him and there were just
five of us and we would talk about
everything and anything and it was not
minuted there wasn't a particular agenda
although we would both come with things
that we wanted to discuss and the
private secretaries would have
established in advance that these were
things that you know I both sides were
like to raise
um I would be really careful about
overly
sort of prescribing that
that conversation you've got to allow a
sort of safe space if you like where
senior policy makers from different
institutions with difference but can
have that informal discussion and in
that informal discussion you know I
would say
I've got a budget coming up I'm thinking
of this I might not do this I might cut
this tax I might not in other words
things that were highly politically
sensitive but I would trust obviously
the governor and this would also apply
to Mark Carney that he would you know
treat that all in confidence he might
give me informal advice not on kind of
per politics or fiscal policy but on
sort of overall Economic Policy if I ask
for it and then you know he would say
well taking that into account this might
be the monetary policy response and I
don't think that in any way
compromises the independence the
independence comes from the
self-confidence of the institution and
that's how you actually make it work and
when it doesn't work is when those
relationships break down you can't have
this conversation very interesting I
mean again uh very much continuity with
the way things had been in the previous
13 years I'd had a series of meetings
with Mervin when he was a chief
Economist prior to the 97 election in
fact I remember Gordon joked that the
only person who actually was guaranteed
a job in um the new labor government in
1997 was Mervin because the manifesto
specified that the chief Economist would
become a member of the monetary policy
committee when it was established and I
also had very regular meetings with the
then private secretary to the governor
uh Mr Andrew Bailey for months before
the 97 election and that that
relationship carried on there was lots
of change happening and it was
complicated but actually I remember
um when Eddie George um stepped down his
mansion house dinner he presented Gordon
with an open letter
which said dear Chancellor I have never
had to send you an open letter and
everybody kind of smiled but actually
that was in a way an expression of the
the the the warmth which it was
established over those years in that
relationship and that carried on
um with Mervin I think the one thing I
would say
um is that it is more complicated since
with um
the the shifting of responsibility into
the bank of England and also the
different Deputy Governors there was a
you know a an open conversation with the
governor but then the decision on
interest rates was not made with a
chance that it was made by the monetary
policy committee with votes chaired by
the the the governor we're now in a
different situation where you have
um within the bank of England
decisions being made by different bodies
with different Deputy Governors
responsible and there will be times in
the future where there is a potential
tension between the view of the
systemically concerned Governor Deputy
Governor or the monetary policy making
Deputy Governor and then the micro
Prudential regulating Deputy Governor
and I just think when you really I'm not
sure whether we've yet worked out
Forum within which those conversations
occur including the the chancellor it it
it in our time it was always clear
that the the governor and the chief
regulator
had a direct line to the chancellor and
um that is less clear
uh today how can I interrupt you see I
think one of the reasons we we brought
about the reforms around Financial
supervision was precisely to force these
trade-offs to be made
uh and resolved and so you know either
take a practical real world example from
the last year you know in the Autumn of
last year the the bank is trying to
tackle inflation
and at the same time there's a financial
stability crisis in ldi Pension funds
and instead of like the monetary policy
Committee in the Bank of England coming
to the chance of saying well we sorry
about your problem with the Pension
funds we're doing this on interest rates
or we're doing this on quantitative
tightening
and then some other Regulators coming
and saying but we've got a real problem
in the Pension funds you know you
actually got Andrew Bailey as the sort
of Central Point who's who's having to
reconcile both and comes up with a
solution which is okay what we're going
to buy guilt for a week or two
um and by the way we're not going to put
this to the chancellor because if you
put it to the chance you'll want to buy
guilts for the next three months right
so you know um I think that was a good
example of that you know a really
difficult situation where you had NPC
objectives going one way FPC objectives
going the other way and you forced the
institution
uh that we've charged with these
responsibilities to resolve that and
you've you've forced the person who
obviously you know you have by
definition confidence in the government
of the bank of England to to make the
trade-off well I don't know if you want
to discuss this now I don't agree with
what George has said and I think there's
some real issues here which we need to
talk through let's come back to it I've
definitely noted I just quickly want to
bring in little Griffiths who's just do
you want to come in thank you very much
yes I warm to the idea of the treasury
of the bank get on closely together
on the other hand is there a danger a
closeness becomes so great that you end
up with fiscal domination
and you end up with quantitative easing
financing what the treasury really wants
I don't know well I think the
the the chancellor and the treasury are
responsible
to Parliament
for the setting and arrangements to meet
the inflation Target and for the setting
and the arrangements to meet the target
for financial stability so in the end
there has to be a dialer which involves
a Chancellor because that is where the
responsibility ultimately will lie and
also that is ultimately where the
balance sheet guarantees will will come
from so you can't you'll be mistake to
cut the chancellor out of that second
thing is when you go to to fiscal policy
um
fiscal policy is a matter for the
chancellor and for the treasury we can
discuss this I don't think there is any
um evidence that we have that our system
has done anything that allowed the
proper management of the coordination of
monetary and fiscal policy from for um
over the last 25 years and quantitative
easing is an issue which um
which is the responsibility of the bank
of England in meeting its objective set
by the chancellor and it's on that basis
that the bank of England has been held
to account for those decisions and it's
on that basis through the setting of The
Target the chances accountable to to to
Parliament I don't personally feel that
anyone has established there has been
either a conflict attention a lack of
accountability or the wrong decisions
made as regards either the coordination
of monetary and fiscal policy I mean
we could debate 2011 to 2013 later if
you like I mean there I've sort of you
know not fully sure
um but but but as far as QE is concerned
I don't see the evidence
let's come back we can come back to QE
and we're bringing all Davidson so yes I
I
uh um studies focused on
the success of operational Independence
the problem we have is that we've only
got a sample of one and
given the experience the varied
experience of a period for 25 years with
the movement of China into world trade
with the 08 crash and the subsequent
measures taken to solve that and then
more recently with what's happened in
Ukraine and so on covid
it's very difficult in that whole mass
of factors to actually pick out what bit
of that was due to operational
Independence perhaps another way of
asking the question would be
if the bank hadn't had operational
Independence would anything have been
any different in which case we can't
really form a conclusion on Independence
well look the first thing to say is that
systems are tested in the face of shocks
and we've had a whole series of shocks
and the semiconductor 98 then ltcm then
we had the tech bubble bursting then we
had the Iraq War then we had the
financial crisis then interest rates
stuck at the zero bound then we've had a
pandemic and the reality is this way of
making monetary and fiscal policy but
monetary policy in particular has has
been robust in the face of those shocks
so that afterwards the system emerged
and has carried on with continued
political and public support so I would
say we have a whole series of points
where the system could have failed and
it didn't and the one time where the
system nearly failed was when politics
looked like it was throwing into doubt
the operation of the framework
Independence proper budget processes the
role of the obr that was the only point
where we've had a crisis which looked
like it was going to run uh you know out
of control and the reason we came
through it was because the system was
was re-established so I think I feel
more optimistic uh than you about the
operation of the framework I think you
could point to two specific examples I
think if if Mark Carney had not been an
independent bank Governor I think his
words on the immediate morning after the
brexit referendum would not have carried
such weight in financial markets and
calmed financial markets I think you've
been seen as a kind of you know a
placement of the government I was part
of the Cameron government people who
said well he's not going to be here for
much longer because you know there's
going to be you know the fact he was
independent helped enormously in that
situation and I come back to the Autumn
of last year which I think is a really
important test case because I think
that's the first time in the last 25
years you've had a government that was
not ideologically committed to
Independence of the bank of England I
was bad-mouthing the the governor of the
bank of England
um and when it came to the obr which I
know is not subject to your inquiry was
actively seeking to bypass it or indeed
discipline you know I think not actually
dismantle it and if anything I would
like the OVR to be put on more of the
independent footing that the bank of
England has put on with powers to
conduct its own forecasts powers to
request information from the treasury so
you don't get the situation you got lost
Autumn where the obr where the
chancellor announces what in effect is a
budget certainly the most consequential
fiscal statement of the last 25 years
and the obr was not allowed by the
chancellor to to do its job and I would
get you know learn from that experience
and put the open and learn from the bank
of England's Independence and find ways
to make the obr more independent and
more robust in the face of um you know
political Vandals
come again
little King
well I want to start by thanking you
both for doing two things one is to
allow very clearly
the arguments for Independence and
as Ed said just now there were an awful
lot of shocks during that period which
tested the framework
and then secondly stressing the
importance of the sort of informality of
the relationship between Chancellor and
Governor which is necessary to make
things a success and can't easily be
defined in terms of
uh you know remit or changes to
legislation which we as a committee
might want to think about it is very
much to do with individuals and
personalities and people being grown up
enough to make that relationship work
and it in my experience under both
parties it worked extremely successfully
there was never a moment
when either party
on either Chancellor of either party
tried to behind the scenes put pressure
on the MPC to take a decision one way or
another
so it has actually I think been been
extremely successful
but what I want to probe you on now a
little bit is that
um
get both of you to talk about the extent
to which
the remit and responsibilities of the
bank
have been expanded since both your uh
times there so even on the MPC Ed
we've now got climate change and various
other things
added to the remit to the bank
what's your view about sort of going
back to the Simplicity and Clarity of
the initial remit what's your view about
how far that's changed and George
I mean the remit of the FPC is almost
twice as long now as it was when you
introduced it what's your reaction to
that if you want to go first and then
George
I think from the the the beginning in 97
we were clear that there would be a
secondary objective and the secondary
objective was to support the
government's objectives for growth and
employment and that was in the original
letter within the legislation but it was
always clear that that was a secondary
objective the Privacy was the inflation
Target and I think the the importance of
the symmetry
and the importance of the open letter
was it allowed the monetary policy
committee to explain that there would be
times we're going through one at the
moment where there is a shock which
moves inflation
away from the inflation Target and at
that point the bank has a decision to
make about how fast to seek to bring
inflation back to Target and it does so
with an ion
supporting the government's wider
objectives for growth and employment and
that is what the open letter system
enables it allows I mean clearly getting
back to the inflation Target is the most
important thing but but the pace at
which you do that and I think that's
been a a strength
um you know it concerns me the idea that
you sort of start to throw in to the mix
other secondary objectives which aren't
really
um
uh
directly affected sensibly by the
instrument that the bank has
um in front of me which is the the um
the interest rate to meet the inflation
Target and you know I think if I was the
bank of England doing stress tests what
are the stress tests I would want to do
and would be to worry about
um risk and resilience as far as climate
changes is concerned and clearly um the
MPC was always worrying in the period up
to 2007 about whether or not wider
Financial stability concerns could
impact upon the inflation Target and why
the objectives of growth in employment
but the government's got to be clear
that that the meeting of an objective
like tackling climate change or reducing
emissions that is a matter for fiscal
policy and Regulatory policy and the
government and to start expecting the
bank to lead on that doesn't seem to be
to make any sense similarly on the
financial policy Equity side I was
supportive and I think in the end
um we got to this point that Cleveland
there's an objective for financial
stability
but subject to that we wanted the FPC
and the bank to have an eye on the wider
impact of on growth and competitiveness
of the city of London in The Wider
economy and that's important because in
the same way as you don't want an
inflation Target which was as low
inflation as possible is better symmetry
is important you don't want to take have
an approach to financial stability which
says you know Financial stability at all
costs because that would be the expense
of the operation of the economy there
has to be risk and there has to be
decision and and and so that's something
which needs to be in the mind of the the
FBC as it makes decisions to use for
example macro potential tools I think
there was just an inherent problem on
the FPC side which is it's easy to
define the primary objective the
inflation Target to measure it
to hold the bank accountable for that
for the public the select committee to
see that and then to have in that
context the conversation about
um the impact on secondary objectives
alongside that on the FPC side you know
as the chair was saying about the remit
this is just much harder because it is
very hard to specify the rebit it's very
hard to therefore hold the FPC to
account for the meeting of that remit
and there is a danger that there is
there's insufficient scrutiny of the
impact of decisions on those wider
growth competitors objectives I think in
some ways it makes it more important
there is scrutiny but let's be honest as
far as the FPC is concerned there's much
much less scrutiny exclusion is much
less
effective there's a much less informed
public debate I think there's much less
discussion in Parliament of the remit
letter so um you know my answer was
King's question is on the FPC I think
the secondary objective is in some ways
more important but I worry about whether
we have transparency and process and
Clarity which properly allows us to um
to scrutinize that effectively thank you
sure yeah
um so I I agree with you that um I agree
with you the implication of a question
which is that um you know we don't have
to turn these letters into kind of
Christmas trees where you put all your
kind of baubles on them
um and it should be straightforward
enough to say you know
as a secondary objective supporting the
government's economic policy and then
you know the government should be able
to articulate its Economic Policy so the
bank should know what it is
um and and now whilst I you know I I
totally respect the desire to get all
sort of arms of the British State trying
to deal with the challenge of climate
change you know I don't think it
particularly is necessary to sort of
single out that objective amongst other
Economic Policy objectives
um on the um I think on the FPC I mean I
essentially agree with again with what
Ed is saying but I but I think it's you
know I think the FPC has been very
valuable
a very variable addition to the bank's
tools and I think
um it would be strange not to use these
instruments uh to try and manage uh kind
of broad you know macro Prudential risks
um
they are intrinsically more complicated
to understand there are there are
several quite a few tools you can use
more than several many tools you can use
um I've read up on your your previous
hearings with um Paul Tucker and John
Vickers and you know I have a lot of
sympathy we're trying to encourage
debate and voting and we should probably
give more thoughts see how that could be
introduced
but but it won't always be
straightforward because it's not just
one target one instrument as there is on
the NPC
um although I guess NPC has found some
new instruments with things like QE
um
but I'll give you a kind of practical
example
you know the FPC makes very important
decisions about mortgage affordability
which has real-world consequences for
millions of families about whether they
can afford a home or not
and it is self-evidently the case that
it is much harder to get a mortgage
these days than it was 30 years ago and
as a result people in their 20s and 30s
find it harder to get on the housing
ladder now that might all have been done
for good policy reasons I.E to make the
country more resilient to financial
shocks to make bank balance sheets more
robust to make sure people didn't get
themselves into debt situations which
you know they couldn't afford
but it has but whilst parliament in you
know the house Lords in the house of
Congress goes around talking about home
ownership
the the regulatory system the FPC and so
on has made that more harder and harder
in one particular angle around mortgage
Finance
um and I don't think that is properly
understood and properly debated and I
don't think parliamentarians give it
sufficient attention
um and I think you know the it would be
good to come up with some ways to
articulate these choices more clearly
explain the real world consequences of
counter cyclical Capital buffers and all
that kind of thing which is very
technical
but does have enormous consequences for
the ability of a small business to get
Finance the ability of a home a
homeowner a family to
buy get a mortgage so on you know and by
the way the committee knows what it's
doing it is you know it's not like the
people on the committee don't know that
they're doing this and they're doing it
in good faith
um so I I think you we can find ways of
sort of simplifying
the consequence of these decisions or
explaining in the simpler terms the
consequence of these decisions
come back in on any of that
can I just ask you very quickly to say
if we could sort of turn the clock back
to Happy Days and uh you will in power
again and you had the chance to
simplify some of the remits would you
want to do that
or not
I've um it's a good question I think we
if I in the kind of governance of the
bank of England I think we could have a
good conversation
with with the governor about and the FBC
about how to simplify the remit how to
make its decisions more transparent to
people perhaps to have a conversation
with how Parliament can engage with
those decisions and scrutinize them
um and I thought there was another point
I think you know this is obviously
difficult territory because I have you
great respect for um all of the current
incumbents but maybe there are too many
Deputy Governors or we could somehow
create some sort of hierarchy amongst
the deputy Governors which I know
something you know previous Witnesses
have raised so you know I think there
are sort of tweaks to the system you
could make
um but broadly speaking you know it's
it's um it ain't broke so don't um
break it I think I think can I just I
mean I would go further than that not on
the monetary policy side where I think
the the specification of the Target and
the way there's accountability seems to
be working even in difficult times I
don't think we're ever going to get to
something as equally clear and simple on
the financial policy side but there is a
problem George alluded to it the reason
we don't have
a um a fiscal policy committee is
because in fiscal policy the decisions
the treasury are taking around tax rates
are first order
distributionally differentiated you know
a tax change there's different tax rates
for different individuals or in
different parts of the country sometimes
affects people's directly in the case of
interest rates in first order terms when
the bank sets the interest rate it's the
same interest rate for everybody I mean
of course there are second order
distributional impacts but it's one it's
one instrument when you go to the FBC
the FPC is making decisions which are
more like fiscal decisions than monetary
decisions in the sense that if you take
a loan to value ratios for example they
impact they have different levels and
impact differently on different groups
of people this is politically more
contentious and I and I don't think we
can simplify that and I absolutely want
operational Independence
for the bank the macro Prudential
decision maker to use those tools what I
worry about at the moment is that the um
that on the financial policy the bank is
too exposed I would like there to be
more cover
given
by the treasury and the chancellor to
not just the objective but the operation
of that objective six months to six
months to try and get closer to the way
in which
the treasury owns the inflation Target
and one of the things I've proposed is
that we we don't simply have a letter
sent by the chancellor
um to the
um the FPC on a annual basis but maybe
more often maybe quarterly or six
monthly the chancellor brings together
the governor but also the key Deputy
Governors who are leading on macro
Prudential supervision and monetary
policy there is a conversation about
risk and macro Prudential risk the
things which are on the agenda from that
meeting the chancellor then gives a
remit which might have a bit more detail
in it
it's then for the FPC to make its
decisions
but to me a remit which is more which
has been discussed in the group but also
with with more specification and in
which the chancellor kind of gives more
political cover what worries me at the
moment is if something was to go wrong
at the moment uh I think the bank of
England on the financial policy side is
quite exposed and um you know I I I I
would rather that the treasury was um
kind of more engaged if you look in
America they have an equivalent they
have a committee called the fsoc
um I'm not saying that that's a good
parallel because there's lots of
complications but the the American
system is different from us and
complicated but essentially the treasury
secretary shares a group which brings
together the key players look forward in
terms of the macro Prudential
developments on the economy that's a
good thing and I um I think if if um if
George or I would Chancellor now I don't
know I can't speak for George I think
that that finding a way in which the
chancellor can own the financial policy
objective in a more detailed way as if
clear on the inflation Target would be
would give the bank some protection
very good looking is it so when glass
breaker I take it that although there
are some differences of perspective in
what you do on financial stability
neither of you are Keen to either retain
or add to the baubles on the Christmas
tree
uh I think it's a good exercise isn't it
every few years to try and simplify
these things and
I think down the remit letter it'll tell
me what's going with a quick question
um you've outlined how the the FPC is
taking decisions which have strong
distributional elements they're making
them more like tax decisions
there's one other factor which I don't
know quite how they deal with it let's
say careless talks um uh cost lives that
you want to talk about some sector you
think not quite happy there there's a
risk here the risk there
and the last thing you want to do is put
that on the public domain because you
precipitate the very thing that you're
trying to prevent
and that I think maybe the answer that
is
there needs to be more discussion
between the bank and the treasury so
they have an absolute sharing of
where these risk factors are who could
be on the brink and where you might need
to intervene but you don't share that
with the wider public and as I say
precipitate what you're trying to stop
especially I strongly agree with that
and I think in a crisis the reality is
the chancellor is going to be showing
the meeting because they have the
balance sheet and in a crisis
it's not enough for the chancellor only
to hear from the governor because there
may be within the now Bank of England
families different views between the
micro Prudential regulator or the
monetary policy maker or the governor
about where risk lies and I think if I
was the chancellor I'd want to hear
those different views rather than all
being
siphon through the one individual the
governor that's why I don't agree with
the way George specified the last Autumn
conversation and if you have a regular
place where that conversation occurs it
doesn't have to be minuted for the
exactly the reasons you said but which
is also the place where the remit is
discussed you established in Good Times
the relationships which you will then
need in more difficult times and you
don't have to invent an ad hoc group
because you've already got the group
established and working so having a
forum where I mean it needs to be
two-way the flow of information between
the treasury and the bank and not one
way very good I'm going to move on to
Lord Rooker
yeah uh good afternoon
um
I'm going to ask about
scrutiny the remit and in some ways the
extensive positive answers you've just
given to both previous questions in some
ways cover aspects of it but I was very
struck with what William Hague wrote in
the times this morning about MPS have
got no time or less time than they used
to have spent on National issues and the
words treasury select committee has not
crossed anybody's lips yet this
afternoon so I'm going to ask
do you think the remit letters receive
an appropriate level of scrutiny and is
there a case
um
but a bit of Prior scrutiny
by the treasury select committee before
they're issued I mean we get
transparency afterwards but and
notwithstanding what you've just done to
the Lord Tumblr I can understand
the reason for saying no but is there
not a case for a greater degree of
Education of the public and indeed
members of The Commons who according to
William Megan I think he's probably
right at my experience are spending less
time on National issues than they used
to
um
well you know I can only speak from my
my time in Parliament
appearing the treasury select committee
was a pretty effective and tough
um Forum to appear in front of as
Chancellor
and you know I would have two uh kind of
scheduled meetings a year one after the
budget one after the Autumn statement
and I would spend a lot of time given
that I also had a lot of other
restaurants but there's a lot of time
preparing for those meetings but they
did have the element of a kind of gotcha
encounter where there were you know a
couple of
Rising style labor MP he's one of whom
is now Shadow Charles out to make a name
for themselves and I don't you know
that's what I was doing back then as
well you know and I was a opposition MP
and you also have a couple of unfriendly
members of your own side also Johnny
okay we were harder to deal with so it
had a kind you know it it was certainly
a lot of heat I'm not sure there was
that much light and therefore I wonder
whether you could find whether it would
be around the remit letters
um another occasion where a Chancellor
could go and it was sort of generally
understood with the TSC that this was
not the kind of big
sort of you know showdown in a in a
highly charged week where you've just
done the budget and it's been argued
over by the different political parties
um and and something that you know and
in my I wasn't speaking entirely
personally I think you would get more
out of you would have gone more out of
me in that encounter rather than my kind
of fences up and uh you know
um so I think that is the case I'm not
sure about pre I mean it'd be an
interesting question whether you know I
I mean I you know we have to confront
the reality that our constitution
uh is if we if we can describe it as
such means the executive is in the
parliament and so I'm always a bit
nervous of saying you know parliamentary
committees I'm talking here about the
house Commons should have got a vetoes
on appointments or
you know
um vetoes on things like remit letters
which go to the core of the government's
Economic Policy because because in
practice you know government should have
a majority in Parliament and then it
would kind of create all sorts of
complications of your kind of pretend
this committee is independent when it's
not really and it would put even more it
would in practice let's be honest you
know and I can say no I've left you know
you'd be going to the chair of the
treasury committee and say whatever you
behave yourself would be a minister in a
year's time right I mean that so uh you
know I think you would the more kind of
weight you'd put on that body the more
you'd Force the executive to corrupt it
essentially
um so I I wouldn't go I wouldn't give it
too much I wouldn't give it sort of
executive power because then the
executive will want that power and find
a way to get that power but I would give
it more opportunity for scrutiny and I
would find at least one occasion a year
where the chancellor has a more has a
less confrontational
um encounter with the TSC
I think the thing I would
um say is I think on monetary policy and
on fiscal policy
I think parliamentary scrutiny of
government decision making is effective
and has become markedly more effective
over the last
um 30 years
um of the 30 years since I was first in
this place in the early 1990s
um and and part of the effect of the 97
reforms on monetary policy was to
enhance
the debate and scrutiny the the fact
that we had NPC members making speeches
disagreeing
voting differently once we got used to
that
was hugely positive for
public debate and
I think we had a monetary policy we have
had in the last 25 years one of the most
educated debates about interest rate
decision making in any developed economy
and I think that the reforms and the way
in which the bank
empowered those reforms and encourage us
as Mervin did in particular different
people to take a different view that has
been really good
we don't do the same on financial
stability Financial policy when I was a
minister I mean I was being summoned to
get to hearings about cash machine
charges or travel insurance but we
weren't talking a lot about macro
Prudential stability I'd be surprised if
you spent a lot of time talking about
those things there was a period where
Andrew chiri chaired the banking
commission where Parliament did play
that role but then that was for a short
period
and and I think it may be inherently
more difficult and more complicated I
mean that just may be a fact even though
we know it's impacted on family finances
and the economy is huge
but it might be to go back to a point we
made earlier there was very little
scrutiny of the FPC minutes
because they're quite boring
because everything is consensual there
aren't votes people don't express
differences of you as Lord Turnbull says
you have to be careful about how you
express differences of you but I think
that the Parliamentary debate and why
the public debate will follow from
whether the bank of England feels
confident
to air those those debates in in public
and I think we have been much much more
confident talking about those things on
the military policy side in the last 25
years and we have on financial policy so
I know reading the transcript that um
both John Vickers and Paul Tucker have
made this point but you know there's not
been group think in monetary policy for
25 years but I think there's more
structurally we could do to move away
from consensual thinking on the
financial policy decisions and of course
it was really difficult 29 10 11. I mean
I think
they dismiss how hard it was to
introduce these reforms but I wonder
whether
evolving that and having more confidence
in disagreement or at least discussion
would lead to a more enhanced
parliamentary debate and better scrutiny
accountability
that's very helpful by the way both
answered with just follow up to Mr
Osborne about
if you could elaborate
on the process
of the development because you obviously
had the opportunity over several years
producing the remit letters I mean did
you for example
um before you issued a reread letter
check it for consistency with the
previous one that you did and in that
respect in that respect as you're
clearly both on your own work so you'll
have read The Exchange I had with Paul
Tucker a couple of weeks ago when I
pointed out that in 2021 which is Russia
cynics letter in contained in a very
clear paragraph paragraph two quote the
government's commitment to price
stability in the Bank of England's
operational Independence remains
absolute
um
the exact same letter with the exact
same paragraph from Jeremy Hunt in 2022
did not contain that sentence
um he really needed to say actually that
situation
I I thought it was a very interesting
question and I was wondering what the
answer was
um
there was certainly you know amongst the
kind of policy decisions that I took as
Chancellor we would spend quite a bit of
time on the remit letters
um and you know there were we did
consider in 2012 2013 in discussion with
uh with the governor you know whether
there was whether for example we
explored we never got Beyond what's got
our first base on this but you know
could you change from to sort of
something like nominal GDP targeting or
average inflation targeting we had lots
of discussions about uh credit
conditions in the economy and which
ultimately led to the funding for
Lending scheme from the bank of England
um so you know the ream and and the
remits letters did look at uh in fact I
think the last three month letter I sent
to Mervin was open the door to forward
guidance and and
um you know we'd actually changed the
remits and allowed the committee not to
to take number of years to return to
Target if it wanted to do so so we did
spend a lot of time considering I have
to say we spend much more time thinking
of changes which we then actually didn't
do so you spend an enormous amount of
time I seem to remember in 2012 thinking
about normal GDP targeting and came to
the conclusion that would be a pretty
bad idea but but it was aired within the
treasury and it was aired in the kind of
just private discussions with the
governor
um so I I I certainly feel it was not a
kind of routine task in the treasury
when I was there because we were dealing
with it you know we were dealing with a
situation of you ongoing credit crunch
essentially and the government and the
the bank you know the interest rates
ready at the lower bound and so on
um so it was given proper consideration
and there was a good and we had you know
top it was top officials in the treasury
were engaged in it very good that's a
very very good way to segue into a
question from conscious of time to Lord
lon's bronze to put thank you um can we
now turn uh return to the um
quantitative easing and in the current
climate of high inflation the um
unwinding of QE
so over the last what 12 years or so
um QE in the wake of the financial
crisis of 2008
um has grown cumulatively from 200
billion pounds to almost 900 billion
post-pandemic in 2021
are with events such as the Eurozone
debt crisis and brexit triggering fresh
bouts of QE along the way
and as a result the bank's balance sheet
had grown
um by almost 500 percent
so my question for you both is really in
two parts the first is do you think
that the bank's deployment of QE has
impacted on its credibility in relation
to its primary task and controlling
inflation
and secondly has QE
particularly the extent of it
and the size of the bank's balance sheet
served to compromise the bank's
Independence
I mean and then the answer to both
questions I would say was no
um
you know first of all I think it was to
the credit of the bank and the then
government the Gordon Brown government
the the Anderson darling's Chancellor
that they developed the QE framework and
I said some foolish things a shadow
Chancellor at the time about it I
remember so um yeah uh but sure enough
when I was actually in the in the real
job I adopted wholesale the Alistair
darling framework that I've been agreed
so
um you know and I think that did show
policy innovation in an exceptionally
difficult situation for the country and
the world
um I'm not really qualified to
I mean I I think it's a bit
harsh to sort of second-guess the bank
in 2020 you know again that was an
exceptional situation a pandemic which
none of us has seen in our lifetimes a
disease whose impact none of us knew
the extent of I mean I I always remember
I would make a broader point you know
about lockdown yeah in those first few
months we were all very scared of
getting this disease I mean we became
less scared as vaccines were developed
and so on but you know and there was a
shock to Market in March 2020 and the
bank of England was I think worried
about liquidity in the system and so I
think with Hein you know you with
hindsight you can say the combination of
QE from the central banks very loose
fiscal policy not just here but
particularly in the US you know which
then continued over two administrations
of the years you know contributed to the
inflationary problems
um but it's a bit harsh to kind of
second guess the policy makers in the
spring of 2020 when they were faced with
already
essentially in the modern era
unprecedented situation
um on I would also say that I think QE
has become a bit of a kind of bogeyman
for basically the failures of
democratically elected governments
to do things about so it's become the
kind of bug bear for distributional
impacts in society which I've seen
people with capital get richer and
you know well okay but that's the role
of governments to do something about
rather than
blaming qemiv and uh equally on kind of
debt sustainability and all of that
you know I certainly never thought when
I was running a kind of high budget
deficit and trying to get it down that
was okay because the bank's going to be
buying all my guilts you know I was very
conscious that we had to maintain
credibility in the in the guilt market
and we didn't want failed auctions and
the like
um and ultimately you know I don't you
know as you see did with the present
government they've
they are aware they have to convince
markets and have come up with you know
they don't like to use words but austere
policies to um
to try and restore credibility and get
the finances into better shape so I I
think QE kind of has become a bit of a
a kind of way out from much harder
questions that should be aimed at
Democratic politicians about how they're
going to you know increase opportunities
for lower income people and people on
low incomes and how they're all going to
do that at the same time as managing
public finances in a way that you don't
lose confidence in markets
So my answer will also be no to to to
um to both
um you know of course it's the case that
um as QE unwinds and as interest rates
are rising this is going to impact upon
the
um the government's fiscal balance sheet
and the government will absorb that and
if it doesn't then suddenly we would be
having a different conversation about QE
but I'm sure it will but I don't think
there was any
um evidence that the bank of England has
taken decisions other than to to to meet
its inflation and financial stability uh
targets I don't think there's any
evidence that it's um it took decisions
it wouldn't have made to meet those
objectives because of pressure from the
the government
um what I think is true is that there
were periods but interest rates were
very low and where the bank was was
worried and thought well maybe some more
QE might help and it probably didn't
help a huge amount but I don't think it
did any damage if you go back to March
2020 at that point where markets were
dysfunctional in the way they were last
um Autumn QE played a hugely important
role and was going in the same direction
as um as as fiscal policy as well
um the evidence that kiwi actually has
had big impacts on
um either interest rates or behavior or
inflation or economic outcomes outside
those periods of kind of gross Mark
instability is pretty pretty pretty weak
so when I say I think probably there
were periods when the bank
was looking for levers and thought well
there isn't any harm doing a bit more
I don't think
potentially did a lot of good
but I think equally nor did it
do a lot of harm because I don't think
it was hugely effective I don't think
those shifts in in kind of in asset
classes May will make a lot of
difference what it has done is George
says is complicated it's complicated
political narratives and given a stick
for some people to beat the the bank
with but um aside from the politics in
terms of the economics
uh outside those unusual and important
moments I think QE is just not that
important
Lord wants to come in and then veggie
yes I just wondered if you could clarify
how you think uh about what is going on
when you have the zero band problem
because normally the theory is isn't it
that the government does the budget and
the bank controls the inflation rate
through the employment rate so so the
bank is in charge of the employment rate
but when you have the zero bound
it begins to lose control of the
employment rate and therefore
the fiscal side
has to become
more involved in the determination of
employment but how how how how did you
see that
playing out during the zero bound period
well I I would say that we were sort of
Saved by the Bell if you like I mean
that um
you know right at the moment and this
wasn't just here I chose to remember the
bank of Japan was sort of leading the
charge on this there was there was all
sorts of talk of what's the next stage
of sort of monetary
um you know um intervention and um
innovation
which which you know
um at some points were gonna look
dangerously low monetary financing at
just that point the kind of world
economy started to pick up and
the sort of issue started to go away
um I I you know I think um
but we were working you know to have
those conversations in 2013 is there
more you can be doing in the monetary
space
um
I
I would still you know
it's still a kind of interesting tool I
mean I guess I mean
there's now an expectation isn't there
in any kind of downturn from the world
central banks are going to stop in and
stop it
and
um you know not one that not to not look
not a downturn caused by then policy to
control inflation but sort of any kind
of Crisis there'll be a massive
um release of money into the system and
and I think an expectation that if that
doesn't work they'll release even more
money in
um and I guess we never really quite
reached the point where we started to
examine what the more exotic instruments
that you could start to deploy in a in a
system like ours were
although although in that period
um to go back to debates of 10 years ago
rather than exotic instruments you could
have just used fiscal policy more in
2011 12 13 and that was a a choice um
that the government chose not to to to
to take in the pandemic in 2020 interest
rates were low there was some QE but the
work was done by
fiscal policy rightly
um in um
2007 interest rates were higher they
came down the work was done by fiscal
policy primarily in that um period and
with the um the banking crisis last
Autumn there was instability but
actually there was inflation so monetary
policy was going in a different
direction but you could have decided in
um 10 11 12 13 to have a
um
old parliamentary debates
the reality is right now we still have
the strongest growth in the G7 yeah well
the
I think the reality is you're warming up
Ferrara the reality has the oecd numbers
show you is that for all of the um
the rhetoric of George he actually moved
fiscal policy from seeming to be about
reducing death the deficit to be to
being mildly supportive of fiscal policy
so he actually did become more fiscally
active he just didn't want to tell
anybody that was what was uh going the
best way around to do it
actually and you know so you could have
just had a little bit more courage of
your convictions yeah well virginity do
you want to come in quick it's not our
remit to um look at individual policies
so at the moment but you know if you
look at where we are today you could
make an argument that the the bank of
England has got it completely wrong I
mean inflation has got completely out of
control
and something is going wrong and I buy
this Rose born you know we are in
unprecedented times of the pandemic and
uh the war in Ukraine Etc but you know
we've got someone who's got it
completely wrong and then we're asking
those same people to fix the problem
is that a floor in the system
and how would you fix that floor if it
is a floor it seems to me you know a
crazy situation with someone who's got
something completely wrong and you go
back to them and say okay well now you
fix this
but uh so first of all I think you know
all central banks
were probably slow to spot the inflation
problem
which you know which came kind of
obviously largely unexpectedly I know
there were some people who forecast it
but largely unexpectedly out of the sort
of tail end of the of the pandemic and
the lockdowns
and was in my view turbocharged by
fiscal decisions in the U.S so
um I don't think the bank of England can
be sort of singled out
among the central banks if anything it
was actually one of the first movers I
think it might have been the first movie
um
and I would say it's got on its kind of
credit on the credit end of the balance
sheet it's it's a dealt with the
exceptionally difficult situation last
Autumn and I the reason I bring that up
you know a very brought up earlier is
because that was the time when
you had an elected government in this
country
challenging essentially the legitimacy
of the bank governor and the bank of
England you had a financial CRI
self-induced financial crisis within you
know this country Alone
um at the time and the bank managed to
navigate through that and it was the
bank's credibility that actually started
to restore
confidence to the markets which then was
followed by the change of government
that was able to do that
um and I would say taking a recent
example you know you've had
I'm not saying these were you know the
problem the challenge was quite as large
as in the U.S or in Switzerland but
I would say the bank of England handled
the Silicon Valley Bank UK
situation
uh far better and with more clarity
than authorities elsewhere were dealing
with you know we did not get into a
situation of guaranteeing all deposits
as the US did and we did not get into a
situation you know of the kind of
confusion about
Equity holders versus bondholders that
you saw in Switzerland and
um
so I think you know the the Silicon
Valley Bank UK
failure was handled very professionally
by the bank and it was shepherded into
the hands of a just just if I made sorry
just to interrupt I'm sorry unconscious
of time
um just putting the question a bit more
directly to you Mr Bulls I mean just
picking up on your point I mean we've
been going on for an hour we've had
basically everyone's saying that your
bed saying that the bank has got a
pretty good clean bit of Health in fact
it's succeeding I think Mr Bullseye
noted that you said that we've avoided
group thinking monetary policy out there
if people had listened to the last ad
I'd say what if planet is everyone on
here we're we're seeing inflation
running a mock and the bank seems to
have potentially been asleep on the job
um and Mr Osborne uses and said well
actually all central banks actually were
behind the curve my question therefore
to you both automatically perhaps put it
to you Mr Bulls is what if anything can
we learn here about what's happened in
terms of uh the track record on
inflation over the last year we were
repeatedly told in this committee is
elsewhere by a number of members of the
bank of England don't worry it's
transitory basically what I'm hearing is
the structures fine the accountability
is fine in the bank and actually
everything is just a factor of group
think globally and I'm trying to see
what I'm missing here and whether or not
there's any lesson at all we can be
learning from what's happened Mr Bulls I
think I mean
the the economic policy decision maker
doesn't have the benefit of our
hindsight
that's just the nature of the the task
so we can you know we talked about the
robustness of the system
um the munchie policy decision-making
process the bank of England in the 2000s
but the reality was in 2005 six and
seven when there was a meeting of the
Deputy Governor for financial stability
in 2006 and the treasury and the FSA
nobody all backed by big capabilities in
their own institutions were seeing the
risks which were rising in our economies
and communicating that either to the
treasury or to the monetary policy
commission that's just a a reality but
we now know that and we've learned from
that but we've managed
to but the system was robust to those
decisions now when you move to the the
last two years the reality is Supply
chains had worked better through the
pandemic than any of us thought I don't
think people foresaw this the extent to
which there would be disruption after
the pandemic and the the re-establishing
of Supply chains its impact on prices I
don't think people saw
um foresaw the fact that we were going
to have a a
a war in Europe and its impact on Energy
prices and we didn't foresee the extent
to which the labor market would bounce
back as strongly as it did and the worry
when we were talking about the end of
furlough was whether we were going to
see a huge rise in unemployment in our
economy in fact things went the other
way so you know with hindsight
of course it would have been better if
we had seen these inflationary pressures
the question is how did the system deal
with the inflation pressures when they
arrived Rose at that time and you know
we could have a discussion about you
know imperfection and communication
because of course there's mistakes made
and we could say well the bank of
England went first
compared to other central banks but
maybe you should have gone earlier and
then the bank of England went first but
then maybe it should have then been a
bit more aggressive in the early phase
but
the reality is that the inflation Target
means when inflation goes outside the
inflation Target you raise interest rate
get things back under control and that
is what the NPC and the bank is doing I
would say with broad-based public
support what is very striking to me is
how there's a lot of criticism of
government fiscal policy and energy
prices actually so far there's not been
a huge controversy around the rise in
interest rates and mortgage rates other
than for a few weeks
I'm just going to say I think I think
with the benefit of hindsight they would
have done things differently but
actually that doesn't mean the system
hasn't worked okay well I just wanted to
push a little harder on uh little
Bridges point which is we're very good
at learning you know the lessons with
hindsight that's what we did wrong let's
make an adjustment third so let's do
this differently but we appear to be in
an era where
um every time you turn around the
um unexpected unknown whatever the
phrase you want to use that so comes and
whacks the system in a way that seems to
be from a regulator's perspective
um completely unexpected that and we're
in a time to when financial markets move
very fast individuals get information
instantly individuals move money
instantly now so so I'm just is there
some change that you could see in the
way that the system is set up
that would give us the capacity to
anticipate risk more effectively and to
to deal with risk ahead of the crisis
hitting a square
well yeah I think it's quite
I think there are certain things which
is extremely hard to
I don't want to go Old Donald Rumsfeld
on you the kind of unknown unknowns you
know I mean it was
you know I know there's going to be a
there's a covert inquiry underway but
the idea that the whole world should
have anticipated that these some brand
new virus and
I question whether in reality you can
kind of plan for every single
contingency I think what is fair to say
there is there are things that are
obvious now
that perhaps we should be doing more
thinking about so it is obvious now that
these Bank runs happen in minutes not
days and weeks and there's no point
sitting around for years think about
that it is the case the Silicon Valley
Bank UK Credit Suisse you know money
moves unbelievably quickly in a digital
banking age where people can move quite
large corporate deposits
extremely quickly so these runs are much
more much quicker than they though I
think the other recent lesson has been
to sort of think that smaller Banks can
be allowed to fail without any kind of
broader systemic effect impact is a
mistake you know turned out
um you know that in the case of Silicon
Valley Bank it was connected to a
particularly important ecosystem around
Tech and Tech startups and whatever and
policy makers sort of after the event if
you like suddenly realizes Bank this
bank was systemically important but not
in the way that they had previously
conceived I think the other thing which
I don't know whether you want to get
into you know a lot of these very large
one of the consequences of the
of the financial crisis you know
um
uh all these years on 15 years on is
that we've actually got a smaller number
of very large important Banks mainly
American
so there has been largely a clear out of
European large investment Banks over the
last 15 20 years and you've got a small
number and you know to what degree do we
rely on kind of international
cooperation to resolve these
institutions and do those International
Arrangements stand up to scrutiny would
it actually work in a crisis yeah in the
case of Credit Suisse the Swiss
authorities and I'm not second guessing
them it's incredibly important
Institution for Switzerland and did
there's some evidence now that it was
written into the bondholders that they
would get wiped out if it was government
intervention so there was some logic to
what the source of doing but it was
certainly came as a surprise to
the UK and U.S authorities
what was happening to what is an
important institution in London and New
York as well as in Switzerland I'm going
to jump in and because I'm query
conscious of time
do you want to have anything
I would like to say in a second just one
thing about the MPC FPC relationship if
you would allow me to because we
referred to that earlier yeah just to
answer bonus creamer's Point look we've
been talking about ways in which we can
improve scrutiny and public debate and
accountability through the session and I
think that's particularly the case on
the FPC side but the reality is that a
global financial crisis we thought this
was a once in a century event
and then a pandemic once in a century
event leaving the European Union
war on the continent of Europe we've had
four Once in a century event in 14 years
I mean it's astonishing the scale of
shocks so I would just say of course
it's imperfect and of course we could
have done things better and of course
the system could be improved but
actually the fact that we've ended up
coming through this with a system which
has been consensual for the last 25
years with changes at the bank of
England still intact and working it's
actually a Triumph
okay very good point I'm going to bring
embarrassville well I I my question was
to some extent covered earlier but
listening to baroness Kramer and to the
responses to it
we need to sit down and look again at
the structures that exist around the
bank and the relationship between the
bank and the treasury because things do
move at a much faster rate than we've
ever seen it do before and how can we
secure Financial stability and price
stability within that kind of
environment we need to look ahead now
and try and find structures that fit and
I first started thinking about this
following the quasi-quarters budget
because it there seemed to have been
shortcomings in relationships during
that time so how do we improve them how
do we make it work there are good things
in what's happened so far but how do we
make it better things for a much quicker
moving economy and international scene
without baubles in the Christmas tree
don't really have a simple answer
because I I started right at the
beginning by saying ultimately the
system depends also on the individuals
at the top
and you can build in all sorts of try
and sort of contingency and sort of
Fail-Safe mechanisms
to protect the bank of England's
Independence in extreme situations for
example but you know if you have a
chance to go around saying he's going to
fire the governor of the bank of England
it's quite old
to deal with that
although I guess in the end the system
followed him so
you
um
we can have a legitimate debate about
whether it makes sense to have macro
Prudential and micro potential
Supervision in the same institution but
actually
destabilizing systems you have to have a
really really good reason to destabilize
them and I and I don't think there's a
really really good reason at the moment
so I understand why we did what we did
in 97 I understand what George did in
2010 I'm not sure I would destabilize
that I'm worried about the two things
within the the system one as I am
worried about the MPC FPC relationship
because I think as George said in this
complicated fast-moving World there are
issues which do
potentially impact upon the remit of
both committees and at the moment we
have a system where you have a group of
Bank of England full-time executive
members who attend both committees and
then independent members who only attend
one or the other and I think if I had
been
a independent member of the MPC in the
autumn
seeing decisions being made in the FPC
which had a direct impact on the
potential outcome for the thing for
which I was accountable the inflation
Target on the basis of a meeting and a
conversation I wasn't at but the chair
of the NPC was I think I'd have been
unhappy about that and um and I think
that may arise more often in the the
future now
one solution would be to have one
committee which looks at Monetary and
financial policy considerations I know
that there's risks in that because the
danger is that the MPC process which is
more clear
and more monthly ends up taking
precedence there's an alternative
approach which I mean I think actually
as I understand they do in Malaysia
where they copied our system have an NPC
and FPC system but where any member of
the MPC or the FPC has the right to
trigger a joint meeting of both groups
if they think a decision is arising or a
risk is arising which they think will
cross over both I just think we need to
think about but protecting the
independent members on one committee or
the other from decisions happening
outside of their committee which impact
upon their um the remit and that's why I
said at the beginning that I was I was I
was I was more concerned than George was
about the MPC FPC process in the Autumn
and then as I said earlier the second
thing I would do is I would try to have
a on financial policy where
accountability is necessarily more
opaque and where Clarity of objective is
harder but where political risk for the
bank is greater I would rather there was
a more structured conversation
involving the chancellor and the senior
members of the bank of England on a
regular basis to have the kind of
conversations Lord Turnbull talked about
and for there to be a more
textured conversation about the remit I
don't think you need that on monetary
policy I think the monetary policy
Observer on the NPC is sufficient I feel
it is not on the FPC side and I think
actually the bank of England is too
exposed and a Chancellor ought to want
to be giving them more cover on
financial stability than we're giving
them at the moment very good Mr Brandon
Jones come back in now yeah just one
very very quick point do you think that
Financial stability and price stability
should be regarded as separate areas for
consideration I'm getting the impression
that that the the the line that you're
taking fuses them more together I think
the case I think I think the bank of
England
must have a role in monetary policy and
financial stability policy and when we
made the reforms in 97 from the
beginning
we established a second Deputy Governor
as well as the monetary policy Deputy
Governor for financial stability and
that was contentious at the time because
there were senior members of both the
bank of England and the treasury who
didn't want the bank of England have a
Deputy Governor Financial stability they
wanted that to be separated but that
would have been the wrong thing
to do but I do think that they are
separate tasks
with separate tools and separate
objectives and often they can be pursued
separately but there is clearly an
overlap where decisions to meet the
financial stability objective can impact
upon the inflation Target and vice versa
and at the moment
I don't feel as though I think we we we
we we discussed that enough is partly
because the FPC process is also to a
page very briefly you know I'm talking
my book here but I think the reforms in
2010 to bring micro Prudential
supervision under the reamer to the bank
of England was very important which was
taken away from it in 1997 and you know
whilst I've as I said at the beginning
support the changes made in giving the
banking Independence I think it was a
mistake to take away from it the
responsibility for supervising the
nation's Banks because you know the the
kind of judgment-based long-term
Prudential regulator sat uncomfortably
in a rules-based conduct regulator
and the bank of England you know I would
observe as an outsider lost some of its
knowledge of what was going on
day-to-day in the financial system and
you had unusual judgments like allowing
the Royal Bank of Scotland to take over
ABN amra in the middle of a banking
crisis which accessibility the problems
that Rob Bank of Scotland had and I'm
not sure A Bank of England LED
Prudential regulator would have allowed
that kind of thing to happen Georgia
strongly strongly advocated at the time
by the bank of England
a bit
the Bank of India was not object to the
um I thought Eddie George was not very
happy with losing yeah no no no in terms
of the ABN Amber look I mean I mean this
is a really interesting conversation and
actually I'm have an open mind about the
system now I'm not saying we should go
back to how it was but it's really
important to remember what was happening
in 1997. you were establishing for the
first time an independent bank of
England
with huge with new responsibilities
separately
you were establishing for the first time
statutory regulation which was an
enormous management and legislative task
bringing together a whole series of
non-stately regulators into one place
our Judgment at the time was that was
too big a task for one institution to do
and you couldn't establish the FSA
without banking regulation hence we went
down that road you've strongly supported
by Lord King and others at the time and
um and then
in the period where the tripartite
system was operating the bank of England
had a huge department for financial
stability and a deputy government
financial stability
that was deeply understanding these
complex that was a choice for the bank
of England to make very good very good
discussion
choice to make at the time lord Turner
do you want to criticus come in on
um just to amplify the point which Ed
Balls has made about the relationship
with these three committees I think
they're three committees I agreement
should be inside the bank and want the
bit that's outside the bank the FCA is a
bit that should be outside the bank but
the relationship between the three is
what we're not as struck by is there's
the governor and three Deputy Governors
and they go to Wall Street
it's not necessarily the same three but
they there's a tremendous amount of
overlap let's call it the caucus and I
think the effect of that caucus on all
three of those committees must have some
impact on
dulling the darling the debate that
takes place because though they are so
kind of preeminent because they they're
the other ones to go to all three I
think the for the outside members to
challenge them given that they've got
much less information much less standing
I think it's quite a quick response
because I'm very conscious thanks to my
LAX time keeping that we're running out
of time so um I think it's a very fair
point I think there's worth sort of
further examination
um I think you could look at the number
of Deputy Governors without being
disrespectful to the current Deputy
Governors I also think and again I very
much don't want to be disrespectful to
either Dave Ramsey or John Connolly for
our excellent public servants but I
don't I wouldn't want the bank England
to be in the habit of taking just
treasury officials being the main source
of oh boys they're officials as much as
we love the treasury you might want to
come back to this and so I think you
know I would look at that I think
there's a general challenge which we did
actually look at in the treasury
wondering I was there while I was there
which is how can we get the sort of
British economic establishment and the
universities to to produce more
um to produce people with sort of big
macro views of the kinds that the
American institutions like other team Ed
Works seemed to churn out and as a
result you know finding people to serve
on the NPC as external members who are
who are British was was actually
becoming harder and harder once you'd
gone through all the kind of obvious
candidates I'm gonna I'm going to
interrupt and sorry because we're going
to come back to that in just a second
with others um Lord layout do you want
to come in well actually everything else
is going to ask has been covered very
good that's a very quick Point unless
you want to ask anything else
I would love to hear a little more about
this because there's
one side I mean the appointment system
is not really the same as the standard
appointment system for say judges
um do if you set up a system like that
where people
would more naturally come in from the
outside you might find the supply
responded too yeah I would just look at
it's a very hard problem to solve I
would say there's a I would say this is
a general
I reserve as someone who was active in
politics for 20 years
and you know there was remarkably little
interaction between government and
university life
in a way that you don't see in the
United States where there's a lot and
that's because the United States I teach
I'm a teacher course at Stanford
University it is at Harvard University
first of all that's interesting I
observe in itself that often we end up
in kind of American institutions
expiration politicians and second
there's a kind of tradition in these
places not just in Economic Policy but
in foreign policy and the like of having
of of a kind of producing people who are
kind of equipped to participate in the
public debate and when it comes to the
NPC you know my observation was once the
bank of England was given Independence
in 97
they went through you know under the
labor government a series all the kind
of obvious individuals who were
qualified in the sort of British
economic establishment had their turn on
the NPC I came in and was able to
appoint three or four people that Gordon
Brown didn't like and therefore had
never been on the NPC and then once we
sort of got through all them we we you
know we started to have to look more and
more abroad to people you know of course
they're still very good domestic members
of them but
but we've increasingly had to look
towards Americans to fill these posts
because the universities don't seem to
be producing kind of macro economists
who with the sort of bigger view rather
than in very
excited to be a more narrow part of the
profession and I remember with Nick
McPherson who you might want to talk to
about this because he sort of took the
lead on it as the government section at
the time we did talk to a number of
leaders of the British academic
Community about what we could do to try
and encourage more of a supply but
you'll you're right that you know we've
got to get the Demand right as well I
mean Georgia is completely right we set
out part of the purpose of the four
independent members as well as to sort
of challenge group think and have that
kind of open debate was also to try and
encourage more people to see that as
something that they would do as part of
their career and it is frustrating that
we haven't seen
the kind of um
flow through that you might have uh
hoped for that's clearly the case on the
NPC side is it even more the case isn't
it on the financial policy committee uh
so and you know I would be
I'd be surprised if most members of the
committee
could name the independent members of
the the FPC I think I would struggle to
to to
um
very good I'm just going to bring a
little Griffis who wants to maybe pick
up on some of these points about
appointments
well can I ask two questions yeah please
do let me as long as that quick the the
first yeah they'll be quick uh the first
question is
you know one field present woman talks
to people who are at the uh co-face
today there's a lot of uncertainty out
there
so far the crisis has been managed on
the other hand there are there is a lot
of uncertainty to what extent do you
think that the bank uh particularly has
uh the macro economic
Prudential risks
really kind of pinned down or to what
extent do you think that in different
parts of the system which we near Banks
Etc
there really is trouble and secondly I
have to say I've been very surprised
today at the fact that you've almost
defended the fact that there is no group
think
in
what I call the monetary establishment
and I think you could make a strong case
that there is a group thing
and also there are so many Treasury
I mean all of the Deputy for the full
Deputy governors of the bank of England
have got treasury experience
and
um I just wonder in the way appointments
are made there is there no way of
opening up the system to have greater
diversity I think when it started there
was greater diversity people like
Charles goodheld and so on but it seems
to me as time has gone on there has been
less diversity
and I think in that sense we do need
something we need a lever to open their
whole system up a bit
well I've I essentially I've
I hope you feel I've agree with the
spirit of that because I have sort of
gently suggested without wanting to be
rude to excellent Current public
officials that you know the bank of
England should have more or more you
know shouldn't draw all of its Deputy
Governors from the treasury I think to
be fair two of them
may have started their careers in the
treasury but they're not can you explain
most of these
um I avoided some of them
all of them
um just checking
um
[Laughter]
at least half of them my appointment
um but something like Ben Broadbent you
might say he's not really you know he is
a somebody who's he was a market he was
from Goldman Sachs he brought a broader
Market perspective to the to the role he
does Sam Woods you know yes was a
treasure official originally but he was
then John vickers's official on the
banking commission and you know
service and give the bank of England
great service I just you're right that
we want to try and encourage
um a bit more diversity
um and but that is there is a challenge
of when you're sitting you know when you
sit there as Johnson is like who can you
point to the NPC and they produce the
list
you know all the other scanners have
already done it
suppose what do you think about that I
think that the
you have to
decide
as a society really is it's beyond the
individual appointments to try and
encourage people to move between
different Realms so if if you decide as
as America does you have people who
spend a period of time in Academia in a
period of time in the treasury then they
go back to Academia or to a think tank
and then they may go to the Federal
Reserve I mean it's a normal thing for
people to structure careers where they
spend periods of time
that that is is much less common in our
system and um and it's quite hard
um to to Simply make that happen quickly
and as I said with the MPC we tried to
to encourage this more and I really
think we fully uh succeeded
um but there are very many more people
in public life now who've been members
of the NPC or have been involved in the
making of Economic Policy today
um that was the case 25 years ago
because of the um the the the MPC and I
um there was a period I think when the
the MPC the individual members were
contributing less to public debate
which always potentially raises issues
of groupthink
um and it might be that in the period
where there's a great focus on forward
guidance that slightly tends to Corral
people into one way of thinking but you
couldn't say in the last nine months
there's been group thinking the the MPC
so my desire is to try and encourage the
same kind of
debate
um on the financial policy side where I
think there is more group thinking there
are structural reasons why that is the
case at the moment I mean
just one specifications it seems to me
that the whole economic establishment in
this country has taken over the new
Keynesian model
and if you look at the bank
as a result for very short-term
forecasting it's fine but in the end it
has no real theory of inflation
whereas if you look at America there is
on this point there is much greater
diversity about a new Keynesian approach
to the whole thinking of macroeconomic
policy and it's that to me that is
actually in a way the most difficult
aspect of group thing to come to terms
with
my reply would be that um in my first
lecture at Harvard as a graduate student
in 1988 I was taught by a guy called
Greg manq a republican who had a dog
called Keynes and whose hero was Milton
Friedman and he explained to me that
actually the right way to think about
the economy was as a synthesis between
important
ideas from from monetary Theory and you
know the historic antecedents of
militism which you see in the work of
Friedman but also Keynes are treated as
of money in the 1930s but also to think
about the way imperfections in in
markets and Imperfections and
expectations can then drive inflationary
processes and that in the end there is a
synthesis of keynesianism and monitorism
which we all employ and within which we
debate and argue can I say I'm suppose I
agree with you completely
well and I would say I'm a pragmatic
monetarist but what I don't see is I
don't see that diversity coming out of
the central bank or the treasury
interesting I mean when you do evidence
from Mr Paul Tucker
um who's who I work with at Harvard a
lot and is a obviously a great man his
main criticism of the um of the all
these treasury officials is that they
hadn't spent enough time in the Bank of
England and that if only and let's be
honest being a central Banker is a
profession and you do want to have that
depth of expertise but there may be ways
in which we can have in the treasury and
in the Bank of England people who spend
time in and out and we think of that in
terms of people who want to be permanent
secretaries who need to have time
managing
um in the private sector I remember our
my old friend Jeremy Haywood and his
time in the financial system but maybe
that needs to be something we think
about intellectually as well as in terms
of practical management experience I'm
not sure whether being a 40-year lifer
is the right qualification to make
difficult decisions but I also let's be
honest I don't want somebody who who has
been charged an accountant for 25 years
and fantasy the career change to do my
cancer operation
do you have any to add on this diversity
of these
yes
I'm still getting over the dog's name
[Laughter]
okay thank you um Barona snakes
our Enquirer is not looking at specific
raised some issues that are worth
reflecting on
um and uh Mr Osborne you spoke earlier
about svb highlighting uh the fact that
money moves very fast and decreased
research as well and that smaller Banks
can be systemically important they
conventionally were not thought of
before neither of those observations are
actually very new
one of the conclusions that we draw that
the FPC is not necessarily very good at
understanding what's actually happening
in in the modern world
I think that's a bit uh that's that's
harsh on them
um
you know I I think sometimes
I mean if you take the Silicon Valley
Bank
I think it's you know it's interesting
because both the the Federal Reserve
and the FDIC so it went out of its way
to say we're not bailing out Regional
Banks
and actually the bank of England
initially said that the svb UK was not
systemic or was that effect and then it
sort of emerged over a few days that in
fact a whole kind of tech ecosystem
depended on this
um you know probably the most productive
part of the economy depended on this
particular bank now you could ask
yourself how impactful the world ended
up in that situation
um but I don't you know I I I I think it
would have been hard to see in advance
personally
um but what was not hard to see in
advance that was that bank runs Could
Happen very quickly
um and I also think it was not hard to
see in advance that Credit Suisse was
good in a lot of trouble
and you know I guess I don't know the
answer but how many conversations were
going on between the bank of England the
Swiss authorities and the U.S
authorities we did an interesting
exercise which um I think is publicly
known but I had much attention in um
where I did a role play as Chancellor
with the treasury secretary Mark Carney
who was then the governor the um uh the
chair of the Federal Reserve at the time
and we did a role play in Washington of
what it was like what would happen and
the various other us regulators and we
went at the sort of tail end of an IMF
meeting where no one noticed we went off
and we did a to the fdaic headquarters
in Virginia and we role played for three
or four hours what would happen a very
large U.S Investment Bank failed
which was code for about three or four
household names and we also did a role
play of what happened if a large British
International Bank failed which was
going over about two household names and
it was interesting you managed to
assemble all these very senior policy
makers in the US and the UK
to run through this scenario
um which in my experience in government
I think it was pretty much apart from
the old military security role play we
did
that was the only kind of thing where I
did a kind of sort of exercise
and we you know what it was really
designed from our point of view was to
establish that in the end the Federal
Reserve would give us a dollar
um
a dollar swap which was not entirely
clear and hadn't been entirely clear in
a previous crisis around Standard
Chartered where a New York state yeah
had threatened to remove the dollar
license from Standard Chartered and then
it wasn't clear whether the Federal
Reserve would give us the dollar swap
facility to bail out a bank that had
been
sort of single that by a us regulator or
a bit not at the federal level
um so we ran through this kind of big
exercise and I thought that was really
healthy and interesting and I promise
you at the time everyone was like what a
one you know we're all very busy people
why are we being asked to do this but it
was a really good exercise and it
actually built a lot of cooperation
between the two teams both the
preparation the exercise and the
carrying out of it and I would be
interested to know whether that kind of
thing still happens whether they've done
anything whether the UK us let's be
honest mostly it's going to involve a
U.S League these problems you know is is
there any kind of role play or kind of
scenario planning particularly at the
principal level
um
and if not you know perhaps it should be
encouraged
of course um
Lord King and I went through two such
role plays in 2006 and early 2007.
um a UK role play where a um a northern
Building Society got into trouble the
collateralized problems which then
infected a major clearing bank and we um
and we learned some important lessons
which um
shouldn't stop the financial crisis
didn't stop the financial crisis and
then we had then we also had time to
pass the legislation on a resolution
scheme that was that came out of that
exercise
and that would have meant the issue over
Northern Rock would have been very
straightforward to handle the most
interesting one on the U.S well we did
it was that when we we had a video
conference that's right and it was the
chancellor governor and head of the FSA
at the American end there were so many
Regulators you couldn't see them all on
the same screen but also if you remember
moving they wouldn't go in the same room
the Americans all had to be in their own
institutions so we were talking to each
other across the three and um and the
The Americans
I mean the as I've written about um in
our UK role play the um
the Lifeboat in Christmas 2006 was that
ABN Emerald
reflect upon that
oh God
so what lesson sorry to come back in on
this so what lessons we should learn
from this um Mr Bulls from these role
plays I mean should we be doing more of
them as well
how did you do more of them and I think
there's you know the Credit Suisse
example is a good one that everyone has
known for some years that institution
was in trouble
you know I think Andrew Bailey has
himself said you know we had a plan it's
just so we didn't know the Swiss weren't
going to follow the plan
um and I think um and you never you know
I think those are the hardest situations
because in the end every jurisdiction
will then look after it's what it
perceives as its immediate short-term
interests but building a level of trust
I think but both with the you know Swiss
the ECB the
Americans is really important and you
know coming confronting the reality that
when you're dealing with Americans there
are many different Regulators so who is
going to be the people you're you know
it's no good if you you might know the
treasury secretary is but if the
treasury secretary says sorry I can't do
anything about this regulator then your
plan doesn't work I'm going to bring in
baroness cromo because I think she was
wanting to get into a lot of this in her
question but well I do I don't know how
much time we've got and you've covered
an awful lot of the ground but this it's
it's this sort of whole International
aspect to it and from what she was
saying Mr Osborne that uh um I mean The
Regulators operate within a national
jurisdiction the markets don't that's uh
um and uh and crises don't so I I just
if you had any additional thoughts
on
that uh whether or not we could enhance
cooperation internationally to deal with
this sort of range of issues that and
whether or not the FPC for example has
the kind of mechanisms that are needed
to to pick up on crises which originate
elsewhere and I'm going to slightly be
on my question because only you know 50
of Finance now is outside of the banking
world and uh is in what we politely call
Shadow banking uh
um adding to the complexity of
Regulation here so it's uh um
can you can you give us some ideas some
thoughts on where we could go to try and
deal with this changing world
it's a big question I mean so yes I
think the kind of international
cooperation is important
um
you know and you can use a number of
fora to do that like the G7 can they
move fast enough
I think they can if they need to
um you know what what these situations
most recently have proved as things can
move incredibly quickly if they need to
the authorities can move incredibly
quickly
um but you you know but but also that
whatever kind of rules you've
established in advance
we're only gonna we're gonna make we're
gonna bail in these creditors we're
gonna you know can all be thrown out the
window
in a crisis
it truth be told you know the US had
told everyone their deposits weren't
insured and then sure enough insured
their deposits and you know that's going
to have quite a lot of implications for
for the U.S banking system and indeed
where people store their money in the
world so I I think you have to be I
think you have to be tolerant of the
fact that however much you try and
prescribe it in advance
in each crisis is unique
and in a crisis National authorities
will do what they regard as in their
sort of supreme national interests at
that moment and you need to therefore
not you know
always have that in mind be realistic
about that
um
and build the relationships both
internally within your end system and
externally with other regulators and
governments in order to best prepare
yourself for that situation
I mean it's always really important to
um to use crises well
um and if you go back to you know when I
started
um soon after bankerville Independence
around the time of um
if you remember the the timed and Easy
in crisis and then
ltcm where it was actually the UK which
first proposed that there should be a um
a financial stability forum and also
that the IMF should report on Financial
Risk at the meeting of the imfc there
was a huge operation opposition to that
mainly from our American colleagues who
just didn't want there to be any
Collective discussion of these
regulatory or Financial Risk issues and
the US has moved a long way over 25
years and we often discover that not as
far as we thought and they were setbacks
but it feels as though I mean the import
I think the question we need to be
asking at the moment to the bank and the
treasury is
what is happening now within those
International forward to try to make
sure the next time we have
one of these crisis is better than this
one but this one was better
than the last one so we are moving
forward but always in perfectly and you
know the truth is that recent weeks have
I mean I think actually the bank of
England came out as well out of the last
couple of weeks but for the Swiss
Financial system and for the US this has
been a a knock
and so I think there's something
interesting though baroness eggs has
been very vocal on this as well which is
the uh you talked about Rescue of
Silicon Valley Bank UK but we may have
hauled ring fencing below the water line
or at the very least given a huge
competitive advantage to HSBC so there's
uh um it's uh it's not 100 perfection
so if you've got money in a crisis who
is in a good position
everybody out for a barrel
excellent unless there's anything
further I'm going to bring it into
conscious of Time Lord virgin do you
want to come in I mean my original
question has sort of been covered I
think but I'd like to just go back to my
uh point about accountability and what
Lord Griffith said about group think in
a world where you know the world is so
much more Dynamic moves so much faster
and again as a man in the street or a
woman in the street it seems to me you
know we've been thrashed the system has
been thrashed six Nils seven nil we're
in a really bad situation and yet we're
sitting here and saying well nothing
needs to change
and I'm like leaving this place be a bit
more optimistic uh you know I would say
we went through a financial crisis which
had all the Hallmarks of what happened
in the 1920s and 1930s and shocking as
it was in the sense of it you know it
did not lead to the mass unemployment
that we had seen in previous generations
we went through a pandemic which for the
first time in our in world history we
could actually pay people to stay at
home rather than having false work and
infected everyone and and we could feed
their families and manage that crisis so
and by the way we've just had a war in
Eastern Europe which is not spilled into
a wider conflagration across Europe and
we've been able to support families
through the winter despite you know
involving one of our major energy
supplies so
you know I would say there's lots of
things that have gone wrong but broadly
speaking these Western systems have
handled
very unusual crises and are not we've
had spectacular economic growth or you
know the opportunities have been what we
all wish them to be but we nor have we
had Mass
unemployment or you know um
you know we've we've
not done badly given some extraordinary
situations I think trying to think of a
better way to express it but you know
you know the systems have not done too
badly I mean following on from that we
had a um interesting discussion in the
Autumn about what was called treasury
Orthodoxy
and it's interesting question is you
know what is this treasury Orthodoxy and
um there have been maybe periods in
history where there was a Orthodoxy of
view but the reality is that in the last
24 five years treasury Orthodoxy has um
has supported chancellors who wanted to
cut the top rate of tax and to increase
it and to increase tax credits and to
reduce them and to reduce capital gains
tax and increase capital gains tax lots
of different
um decisions important economic and
distributional decisions to have
Regional development agencies or to back
um elected Mayors but
consensus of the last 25 years is to
have an independent Central Bank and
clear fiscal rules and independent
forecasting as has emerged through the
Nao role we had and then to the the obr
and proper respected budget processes
and what happened in the Autumn was an
attempt to rip up in the name of
challenging treasury Orthodoxy
that cross-party consensus about the
right way to make economic policy and it
was a catastrophe and it ended up um
restoring that sensible way to make
modern economic policy in an open
economy like like ours and I think that
is a very positive thing and that's
actually happened with public support
now you're completely right
um in order to see off populist
political pressures it's also important
that people feel that inflation comes
down and their energy bills are
supported the economy grows and all
those
those things and if we don't sort those
wider things out then um our politics
will continue to be to be challenged but
you can't lay
all those wider economic and political
objectives at the door of the bank of
England for precisely the reason Lord
King says which is that is to um add too
many secondary objectives to um to to
the institution you're examining in this
inquiry but the institution in this
inquiry has been strengthened by a
populist attempt to rip up the system
and actually the system has emerged
stronger as a as a result
my question has just been answered okay
thank you very much possibly or
negatively
good question Bill Griffis I'm glad you
asked one question about the court of
the bank of England
my sense is that the court has actually
gone down in status
uh I I was once a member of it joined in
82. all the other the other 11
non-execs Adrian Cadbury John Berry
David Scully Eddie George brought on the
agenda monetary policy for the first
time since 1957 and the bank reads
scandal
we met once a week on a Thursday for uh
from 12 till 1 followed by lunch it was
a very close relationship between the
senior Executives at the bank and
Outsiders and they obviously talked a
lot all the time and there was a lot of
advice given and so on my sense today is
that the experience of people who are on
the court has really
declined
and as a result the court plays a
different function
and I just wonder whether it will be
much more helpful to the governor the
deputy Governors if there weren't more
senior people there more people who are
running big companies and things and had
more experience than we have at present
I'd very much like to know what your
view on that would be I did look at
reform of the course on a couple of
occasions or rather proposals were put
to me that we should create some kind of
more modern border and I just thought
I'm not going to be the childhood tears
on the court after 300 years
depressing thing to do
um I
I didn't know whether you see I I you
know I'm probably speaking beyond my
knowledge here I I wonder whether this
the financial system and the private
sector was different in the area you're
talking about that you would have sort
of british-based Institutions these
individuals would be prepared once a
week as you say to come and give the
governor
the benefit of their views and I I
wonder whether you'd be able to sort of
assemble such a group in the modern
Financial Services System today
um and I also think in some ways the
kind of Bank of England's intelligence
and connection with the financial system
has been more formalized through the pra
um
was the case then so you know I don't
think you necessarily need that I think
the court performs the function it does
at the moment of I guess a bit of a sort
of sounding build and a connection with
the city and then performing the kind of
corporate functions of running a large
institution and you know remember the
bank of England is subject to all the
kind of pressures that any modern
institution is around you know workplace
rights and equality and all that and so
you know I think the Court's trying to
do that job
um I don't know if it's the right
institution to be the sounding board
that that it clearly was when you were
on it
very good looking do you want to quickly
you've both spoken eloquently about the
importance of Central Bank Independence
and when you said
um George about some people who put
proposals to you change Court I couldn't
help thinking instinctively that the
motives of those who were putting them
forward were to try to get more treasury
control over the budgets of
and clearly a key part of independence
of an institution
is it's having its own budget
and
I I you know in the in the days that we
were both involved in all this the bank
had a five-year settlement uh it was you
know area were quite tough for me to
justify what that five-year
settlement was but it couldn't be
changed quickly in the light of a
particular problem that had come up
where challenging Financial Independence
could be seen as part of a bargaining
threat to influence policy and we just
wondered if either of you have a feel
about the merits which have resulted
from giving that away essentially it's
now basically an annual settlement
um
you've got the audit Commission Now
auditing the bank
which certainly when they came to speak
to us about it they were utterly
incapable of auditing any complex
Financial operation which was really
what the bank was involved in
um
do you think that where we are we've got
to is
potentially a threat to Independence
because we've lost that longer term
Financial settlement for the institution
dude I honestly remember the kind of
settlement for the bank of England being
a kind of issue that I spent a lot of
time
on
um
and
um you know the general complaints in
the treasury was the bank of England
officials were paid a lot more than the
territory officials those results quite
often people migrated from the treasury
to the bank for for kind of paying
rations issues
um I I mean I I would instinctively
agree with you you want to you know
secure a long-term budget try and make
it independent of the government of the
day or not depend on the government day
but have some sort of security for a bit
being regularly changed I would do the
same with the ABR it's actually made the
ABR a bit more distinct from the
treasury and separated out from the
treasury run replicate some of the
structures of the bank of England
um
so yeah I mean I I sort of take you your
word of describing that there's a
Potential Threat but
we've heard today it's got a trillion
pounds on its balance sheet so
it can still afford to stop the lines
here
can I just ask sorry official go to the
treasury can I ask just a very final
quick question from me um on deed of
Indemnity um do you see any reason why
that can't be published we asked the
governor of the bank of England he said
it could be the government uh in a
written answer seemed to say in the in
December they said publishing it would
likely expose sensitive information so
we're getting very different views from
the treasury end I personally I would
not know why
um they couldn't publish it but that
doesn't mean they should they should
just perhaps elaborate on why they don't
want to very good I'm looking at my
colleagues within here we've covered a
great deal of ground thank you very much
we were meant to go on for an hour and a
half but thanks to your excellent and
informative questions yes to answer the
the question at the very end I've not
been involved in Bank finances for a
long time George when I was your
Chancellor and I spent rather more time
on the household of the um the crown
finances rather than Bank finances but
in my time very interesting of all these
all these issues um you know if I was
ever concerned about these issues I
would have um I'd have asked are
extremely tough and um public
service-minded non-executive chair of
Court baroness Nokes for her view
because I knew that she would she would
know the right answer and so that's what
if I was the committee that's what I'd
probably do this time excellent thank
you
um
raise indeed
um thank you both very very much very
very interesting session um we've
covered a great deal of ground and
you've both raised some very interesting
points which we may come back to if you
felt able to just to flesh out just in
writing um if you if you're able to and
willing
um for our inquiries we're very keen to
sort of offer up some practical thoughts
on uh improvements that might be made
um so getting views from you on those
points is incredibly valuable thank you
both very very much and with that we'll
end the session